indonesia's covet 19 situation is
currently
a worst case scenario according to a
government minister
earlier in the week the country
surpassed india's daily totals of corona
virus cases
registering more than 56 000 the uptick
in cases has been blamed on the more
infectious delta variant
first identified in india worst hit are
the islands of java and bali
some hospitals here are having to turn
away patients because they don't have
capacity
and enough oxygen the government has
imposed newer tougher restrictions
to control the spread of the virus but
for some
it's already too late
[Music]
the last rites performed for a victim of
indonesia's new devastating wave of
covert infections
a team of volunteers support the police
in retrieving the bodies of those who
died at home
and there are more and more of them
on the first day we only received a call
for one death
on the second day there were three
deaths but today
a week after the group was formed there
are seven
so the situation is getting worse
many of those who die at home simply
weren't able to get a hospital bed
the explosion in covet cases has left
wards overflowing with patients
some of them have to be treated in
makeshift beds and hospital hallways
experts say that the government failed
to take adequate measures to prevent
this crisis
the government also reported that at
cheltenham
also everywhere in indonesia in most of
the
district hardly hit by the prophet 19
i would say that this is
more or less in your situation and maybe
could be even worse and like in india
two months ago
oxygen here is also starting to run
short
with many covert patients being treated
at home there is huge
demand at this oxygen filling station
the pandemic has forced me to come here
and buy oxygen for my mother
she's sick with covert and i'm trying to
give her oxygen therapy at home
most people here are buying oxygen for
infected people who can't be treated at
the hospital
and they have to care for them at home
so far only around six percent of people
in indonesia have been fully vaccinated
but vaccine deliveries are finally
picking up speed
raising hopes that this latest explosion
in cases
can eventually be curbed
and joining me now from jakarta is
epidemiologist dr
pandu ryono who's been monitoring the
corvette crisis
in indonesia dr ryono welcome the
situation has been described
by a government minister as a worst case
scenario
could it get as bad as india
yes uh the pattern of the increasing
cases
is like india you know we got
a sin start early june
the increasing cases is very fast and
almost step up like vertical
vertical increasing it looked like the
india patterns of the increasing of
cases
it means that also we got the same
problem like
india that our healthcare collapse
because
all hospitals or the full people who got
want to do got taking
care and also have difficulty
to get the oxygen we got
a crisis the oxygen deficient you know
because all the patients demand for the
oxygens and also many hospitals run out
of hospital because
we got demand increasing demand from the
people
who got infections and also another
problem is we run out of
bad icu and also
the drugs for taking care of the
patients
everything that you're saying is what
happened in india just about a month
back
i wonder therefore if indonesia did not
see this coming
they see this coming but they don't know
they will
hopefully not like india and
that's why the problem is we are waiting
until we got the last uh finally we got
the
increasing cases the actually
uh we could prevent it uh as early as
possible like
before ramadan or ira fitri festival
we got a lot of massive mobilizations
from in java from jakarta to jaffa
islands
and and at the time also we already got
the delta farian but still not dominated
after the massive mobilization during
ramadan
festival the increasing delta dominate
in our country then we followed the
increasing of the cases it meant until
now
we cannot controlling the pandemic
because
these delta variants and also
the late response from our government to
god uh to stop the uh to social
restrictions
it means that uh that's why it's very
very worse canary or not
will we're coming in the near future now
this spike in cases as you correctly
point out is also
because of the delta variant uh you're
an epidemiologist
can you tell us what we know about this
variant
why does it spread so fast and why is it
so deadly
yeah because in in delta farian actually
already we already identified
since january and then we
see the old variants like old fighters
still doing it and then after
mars will be increasing more because
we'll look at
the ends of mars already tipping of the
infection
in some city and it means that now it's
become dominated because
we find out the transmission is
two times or double than before and also
the increasing of fatalities
it means that this variant is very very
dangerous
because we cannot stop the pandemic stop
the transmission
even in one person's got the infection
suddenly and all the member of household
in the in the household will be also
got infected and died and also the
problem is
uh the hospital
cannot accept the new patients
mostly is now uh people dying in their
home
and also uh dying in the in the
in the emergency room right we leave it
there for the time being but thank you
so much for joining us today i talk to
rio now